[Music]
Oh Sheila so Kristen
hey guys Pete here the only thing that
could tear down the house of the Dragon
was itself today I'm going to be talking
about the first episode of the new
series set in Westeros almost 200 years
before the events of Game of Thrones I
would say that it was mostly a solid
start and I say that as someone who
knows where it's going from having read
the book I'll be breaking down what
happened in The Heirs of the dragon and
telling you what I thought about it and
I'll be trying to do that in a way that
won't spoil what comes next I will be
mentioning interesting details in
history along the way and I'll try my
best not to hit you over the head with
that if it's not completely necessary to
what's going on and with that out of the
way let's get into it the series opens
with a slight flashback to the great
Council of 101. that's 101 AC or after
aegon the first conquest of Westeros in
case you have no idea who this Dragon
riding family is they come from a place
called Old Valeria to the east there
they were a minor house but also
happened to be the only dragon Lords who
escaped before a cataclysmic event known
as the Doom destroyed Valeria in a day
they weren't just lucky beyond their
ability to bond with Dragons some of the
targaryens have prophetic dreams and
danish the dreamer urged her father to
leave after she saw Valeria burn in one
of hers they brought their dragons and
their Valyrian steel and they moved to
an island off of the coast of Westeros
that they'll call Dragonstone and it
can't be understated just how powerful
being the only family with Dragons made
them about a hundred years after that
aegon and his sister wives bessenia and
rhaenys conquered six of the Seven
Kingdoms that existed in Westeros at
that time aegon was crowned the first
Lord of the Seven Kingdoms even though
Dorne hadn't yielded and 100 years later
his grandson jaharis called all these
Lords to harrenhal for the council at
this time House Targaryen was about as
powerful as it would ever be as an older
rhaenyra tells us in voiceover they had
10 adult dragons and no power could
stand against them King jaharis reigned
over nearly 60 years of peace and
prosperity and before tragedy took them
away he had what every King wants he had
an heir and a spare in his two adult
sons he actually had 13 children and
almost none of them outlived him but
that's all just to say that when you
have what amounts to Magic blood and you
keep marrying your relatives to keep it
in the family matters of succession can
get complicated after losing those
remaining Sons jaharis opted to let his
Lords decide who would take over over a
thousand of them made their way to
harrenhal to help him choose between
princess rainey's Targaryen The King's
eldest descendant and her younger cousin
prince viserys who was his oldest male
descendant the Lord chose viserys and in
doing that they set the precedent and
that a woman would never inherit the
Iron Throne basically succession would
be decided through the male line for
what it's worth as far as targaryens go
chairs was a good King he wasn't a great
father especially to some of his
daughters but he was a just ruler who
kept the realm peaceful and did things
like building roads that improved
people's lives remember the King's Road
that stretches from King's Landing all
the way to the wall that's part of what
he left behind and doing things like
Consulting with the Lords on the line of
succession is part of why he was
effective this was a reasonable way to
avoid war over who would replace him
that works pretty great for everyone
except the Targaryen women who get
passed over and that's something that we
will come back around to at the end from
there we jump forward to the ninth year
of King viserys the first targaryen's
Reign on the title screen it tells us
that this is 172 years before the death
of the Mad King heiress and the birth of
his daughter princess Daenerys Targaryen
it's a great choice to open the present
timeline with rhaenera riding her Dragon
sir X it shows that she bonded with her
Mount at a young age and just how common
it is for the targaryens of this era to
ride their dragons no one even looks up
when she flies by I just mentioned
Daenerys and you remember by the time
she hatched Her Dragons people had all
but forgotten them so we know that we're
in a different time and for good measure
we get a look at the intact Dragon pit
that looks a lot different than when
we'll see it again in the seventh season
of Game of Thrones all of this looks
fantastic and it's a great way to start
things off on the right foot because
this episode has a lot of table setting
to do and a bit of a whirlwind you get a
look at King's Landing and the red keep
you meet her mother Queen Emma and get a
reminder that producing children is
considered their Duty as their way to
serve the realm you also meet her
father's small counsel and I think they
did a pretty good job of planting the
seeds of who all these characters are in
a short amount of time one thing that
stood out to me that's promising is that
everything feels intentional as I
mentioned they have a lot to get through
a lot of people to introduce and it felt
mostly restrained in not over explaining
things there are some natural questions
that arise from what you watch here why
is Corliss Valerian talking about this
thing called the triarchy this Lyman
beesberry doesn't hold back from
speaking his mind to the king as opposed
to Lionel strong what's up with that guy
is he a little slow or is he just a man
of few words of course all the people
closest to the king will have important
parts to play as things take off
especially his hand Auto Hightower the
sea snake cordless Valerian who they
didn't Focus too much attention on here
and the council member who's missing his
younger brother Damon in his absence you
get a real sense that Otto isn't a fan
and get an idea of why that is when
rainera meets him in the throne room I
guess this feels like old news now but
if you haven't been following following
the trailers closely you'll notice the
throne looks a lot more menacing than it
did by the time Robert Baratheon sat on
it after his successful Rebellion
against the Mad King heiress this is
closer to how it was described in the
books and you also notice that the
throne room is missing the star of the
seven adorning the windows renera and
Uncle Damon have a conversation in high
Valerian to show that they are close
maybe too close considering their family
is known to be super into incest their
use of this language illustrates that
they share something and he also gives
her a Valyrian steel necklace which of
course is related to their Heritage
having him sit on the throne is a way of
saying hey look this guy doesn't
necessarily follow the rules and you get
a vague idea about his ambition when he
says it would be his chair he would be
the heir if her mother doesn't manage to
give her father a son most of what's
Happening Here and what comes after is
added by the show to develop the
characters I don't think it's necessary
to point out all the differences as we
go but I will say I think most of them
make sense to make things work better in
a TV show probably the one that jumps
out the most is that in the next scene
you find out that rhaenera and Otto's
daughter Allison Hightower are close
friends this is never developed in the
books and it just serves as a way to get
to know them better while adding a
dimension to what happens later you see
that rhaenera is more spirited and that
Allison might be the more clever of the
two I mean she's lugging around giant
books and two-thirds of her scenes that
has to mean something right what stands
out from these two scenes is the fact
that raniera who is very young at this
point in the book wouldn't necessarily
have ambition as a princess it's just
the life that she was born into and as
she tells her friend what she's really
interested in is riding her dragon and
eating cake it's the people around her
that are concerned about the shifting
dynamics of power as her parents are
trying to deliver a male heir to to shut
down any problems that might come up
related to the succession
at the same time in this episode you get
the idea that Uncle Damon might be more
interested in power through this brutal
sequence of his City watch gelding
rapists and lopping off the hands of
pickpockets you get the idea of why the
small Council isn't enthusiastically
United and wanting to see him become the
next king this role is also the last in
a line of different positions viserys
has installed him in with Otto Hightower
undermining his Fitness for each one
along the way the violence on display
doesn't just call into question whether
or not he would be a good ruler after
all as a second son that's not his
Birthright but it's also about a larger
Point that's just under the surface and
a great small character moment a bit
later we see rainey's react when real
violence breaks out at the tourney with
the size she says and the day grows ugly
and goes on to lay out the unintended
side effect of 70 years a piece it's
said that the seeds of War are often
planted in times just like this because
the warrior class and a guy like Prince
Damon who spend every waking moment
training constantly for battle have
never known real war it's interesting to
watch where that comes out and how that
lack of War not knowing the real Horrors
involved informs Decisions by several
members of her family as the story
continues and I just want to say that I
love how they had her play this with
this sort of disconnected disdain for
what was going on as she sits above it
with her family and sips from her cup of
wine this is a story about succession
and people's relative positions and
wanting to hold on to power but it's
also a tale about people who never
understood how bad War could be or
thought that it wouldn't affect them
directly so it's great how they play all
these mid episode scenes off of each
other the small council's response to
Damon's methods as head of the city
watch his blowing off theme with his
favorite cortisone massaria that that
ends in impotence his notable skill in
the violence is entertainment of the
tourney and then they juxtapose all of
that with the horror that unfolds for
Emma during childbirth this was a
complete shock to me since this is a
scene that's taken from a different
character in another part of the book I
knew that she'd die and her son would
only outlive her for a short period of
time but wasn't expecting to see beceros
have to make the decision to let Grand
maester Melos try to save the child
through an emergency C-section it was
difficult to watch and it was certainly
a choice to include it they could have
easily cut away after their conversation
and you would have understood what
happened but I think it was a choice
that makes sense in a way all the
violence that's happening is sanctioned
we watch as the men smash each other's
heads in for sport and Glory while Emma
is cut to Pieces without any say in what
happens to her when for no fault of her
own she can't fulfill her purpose of
providing an heir it's a great nod to
the inevitability of things in this
world for these characters and how
things are quite different for men and
women the show did a good job of setting
things up so that we know Emma sees this
as her role an idea that she'd pass on
to her own daughter that viserys
respected her decision for this to be
her last pregnancy at least in that
moment and that still neither one of
them was prepared for what they
encountered on the battlefield that was
her bed mother and infant son are
cremated by raniero's dragon sirax and a
small family ceremony
Otto and the rest of the small Council
immediately bring up the succession
which prompts a meltdown from viserys
who's in mourning but as ill-timed as it
might have been it put some things into
motion Otto has a heart to heart with
his daughter Allison where he encourages
her to go and try to comfort the King
Damon is comforting himself and his
brothers in the gold cloaks out of
brothel and what could best be described
as an orgy I wouldn't say he was
celebrating though it's actually a
pretty great small performance where you
can't tell if he feels bad about his
brother or if he might hate himself for
the life that he's chosen to live it
certainly hints that there might be more
to the character but he makes a remark
about the deceased being the heir for a
day that Otto is quick to run and tell
the king about and that earns him a
ticket out of King's Landing he leaves
with massaria on the back of his dragon
craxies and his brother makes a decision
he calls for his daughter and they talk
in front of the skull of valerian the
black dread the dragon that aegon the
Conqueror rode and the one that viserys
rode himself until it died of old age he
tells her that he's making her his Heir
and then the show adds a bit of
information that George R.R Martin has
hinted at but notably didn't mention in
any of his books including the huge fake
history about House Targaryen that this
show is based on he lets her in on a
family secret that is only passed from
King to Heir when he came to Westeros
aegon had a dream he first saw the end
of the world of men it is to begin with
a terrible winter gusting out of the
distant North aegon saw absolute
Darkness riding on those winds and
whatever dwells within will destroy the
house of the living when this great
winter comes all of Westeros must stand
against it a Targaryen must be seated on
the throne to unite the realm aegon
called his dream The Song of Ice and
Fire and this secret has been passed
from King to air since his time and now
you must promise to carry it and protect
it I've known about this for a while and
I'm still not sure how I feel about it
on the one hand it connects the two
series and if it's coming from the
author himself then I suppose on some
level it's not up for debate on the
other it sort of changes my thoughts on
who the targaryens are and why they
conquered Westeros in the first place
it's not to say that both of those
things can't exist inside this universe
it was just sort of a surprise and so I
suppose we'll have to wait and see what
they do with it what I liked more here
was his warning about the idea of them
controlling the dragons being an
illusion he says that they're a power
that men should have never trifled with
and one that brought Valeria to its Doom
even though his earlier dream about his
son being born with an iron Crown didn't
pan out the way he thought it would
maybe viserys is a little wiser than we
give him credit for either way the king
calls his Lords to the throne room and
declares raniera his Heir you see her
smile at her father turned to look at
the crowd and then it cuts to Black
while it looks as though the weight of
the realm is resting on her shoulders
and in the black you hear the sound of
dragons I thought this was a really
promising introduction to a story that
if I'm being honest wasn't one of my
favorites in the greater ice and fire
Universe I thought it was great as a
historical footnote about something
tragic that has to happen but wasn't
sure how it would translate into a
multi-season series that is essentially
becomes a horrors of War Story going in
I was thinking the show needed to do two
things established itself is distinct be
something different than the show that
came before it while leaning into some
of the things that Drew us to that in
the first place also it needed to find a
way to make us care about these
characters I think the premiere does
both of those things while having to
deal with being more about setup at the
same time I think most of the issues
that I had with it could be chalked up
to that it's a Premiere it has to
introduce the world there's no getting
around that it's interesting though
because what really works here is all
part of a calm before the storm seeing
rhaenera in her phase where she's known
as the Realms Delight is a great
introduction Millie Alcock does a
fantastic job of making her seem
distinct from her family enough to Make
Her Shine even if it is just part of the
Innocence of her youth I really
appreciated the through line with her
saying that the only thing that could
tear down the house of the Dragon was
its self in the beginning of the episode
and then at the end saying that everyone
says targaryens are closer to God's than
to men but they say that because of
their Dragons without them they're just
like everyone else those two lines do a
lot of work to set things up and I like
how they use them as bookends as far as
the Leaning into things we already like
part the score the set design the
costumes all of that is up to the
standard we expect in some ways it even
seems better the world looks authentic
and lived in and there are details
everywhere to keep the hardcore fans
satisfied there are two other areas that
I often hear other people debate but I
don't usually pay that much attention to
CGI and wigs the former seems pretty
good to me normally as long as the CGI
doesn't take me out of the story I'm
okay with it but the dragons seem to
clear that Mark by a wide margin the
wigs on the other hand actually do kind
of get on my nerves here but it's more
about how the silver reads as gray and
May makes all the characters look older
than they should be like it's supposed
to be silver and they're supposed to
look really otherworldly and cool but it
just didn't seem to work for me and this
is compounded by some of them being much
older than what they're actually playing
for example rhaenys and viserys are
supposed to be in their mid to early 20s
at the Council of 101 and when I checked
by asking my wife how old she thought
they were supposed to be she guessed
much closer to the actors ages in real
life it's a small thing and we are going
to be moving forward in time anyway but
it really kind of got on my nerves when
I went back to take my notes they pulled
off the attorney and the jousting
especially that shot of Damon sliding
over the rail and some pretty badass
armor and I like that they aren't shying
away from keeping it as a show for
grown-ups by including the nudity and
sex which are a big part of how these
folks spend their down time in the books
they managed to make most of the
characters seem interesting even though
they didn't spend much time with any any
of them for example Auto seems like a
scheming douche especially after he sent
his young daughter to the king's
Chambers to comfort him while wearing
one of her mother's dresses but he's a
necessary douche and you get that Beyond
being absolutely caught up in his
distaste for Damon he's effective at his
job after all while viserys is likable
enough it seems apparent that ruling the
realm is in his strong suit and don't
take my word for it or Patty
constadine's great depiction of that the
fact that he keeps getting cut by the
Iron Throne is really the only evidence
you need I guess the next trick they
have to pull off is to flesh out the
main characters and make us want to
watch them if we can't root for them
sometimes there's a welcome honesty
present in watching bad people do bad
things as it speaks to the
irredeemability of the systems that
perpetuate the underlying conditions and
sometimes it's just viscerally
satisfying to watch fictional depictions
of people tearing each other apart the
show will no doubt deliver those things
in equal amounts what I hope is that
I'll be tuning in because I care what
happens rather than just not being able
to look away I think the dragons will
keep some people coming back but the
question of why they're not around
during a game of thrones is gonna start
to hang over things I mean a part of
even the most casual fan must know that
it's not like they formed a union and
decided to live out their lives in the
Hills after retirement so I'll be
interested to see how people experience
that and I think that's a good place to
leave things let me know in the comments
what you thought about the premiere and
what you're hoping to see in the
upcoming episodes I'm not sure if I'm
gonna do episode Recaps throughout the
whole season this is going to be a
saturated space so if no one watches
them I'm not sure I'll be putting this
much time in each week but I'll
definitely be watching the show and will
probably make different videos instead
so please like this video If you enjoyed
it please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for for
watching I'll talk to you soon